Ukraine is preparing a new
counter-attack but what does this mean
and will it change the course of the war
well we don't know until they launch it
and that's something that only a few
people in Kiev know when it's going to
be where it will be and quite what it
will consist of almost certainly it is
some sort of armored attack with heavily
armored forces to punch through some
part of the uh the Russian occupied
areas of Ukraine which are that
semicircle from the the donbass round
through to the the air of mikalayev in
the Southwest
and the purpose we think of that is
probably that the ukrainians will punch
southwards if they can in order to
threaten Crimea
probably can't take Crimea but they can
put themselves in a position to threaten
Crimea and if they do that then they
have got something politically to
bargain with against the Kremlin
sometime in the later summer or the
Autumn but we don't know we're only
guessing we'll see when we see what the
ukrainians have decided to do with the
forces which are now building up
this counter-offensive is really
important because it's there to convince
both the west and Ukraine's own
population that they can win this war in
some meaningful sense
the ukrainians have not just got to do
well in this offensive I'm sure they'll
do well anyway but they've got somehow
to be decisive they've got to be able to
change the balance of forces on the
battlefield and the Western world that
is supporting Ukraine have got to feel
that therefore the ukrainians now might
be able to win they might be able to
throw the Russians out of their
territory over the next year or two
years if it looks as if they won't be
able to do that if it looks as if this
war will just go on
surging one way and then the other then
the view is that the Western World will
very quickly get fatigued by Ukraine and
won't be prepared to support Kiev in its
aims of throwing the Russians out of the
territory that they've conquered so this
offensive is politically very important
because it has to convince the West that
the ukrainians can't just do well but
actually win in some significant way
that's a pretty big ask when you look at
the way the forces are lining up
[Music]
of Russian response is quite an
interesting one so far the Russians have
pulled back a little bit from the the
tempo of operations
the restricting their usual ammunition
not because they don't have it but
because they're saving it and I'm pretty
sure they're holding back quite a lot of
their own heavy metals some of their own
armor they're waiting to see what the
ukrainians will do and so we've seen the
tempo of operations pause a little bit
in the last two or three weeks the
Russians are holding back like the rest
of us waiting to see what the ukrainians
will do when they see what the
ukrainians will do then we'll see how
the Russians will respond but but they
will respond and they will respond I
think fairly vigorously
in a sense the West is behind all of it
the ukrainians are determined to do this
and they're confident that they can
achieve something significant even
decisive but they can't do it without
Western Equipment and so what the West
has done is provide at least 200 maybe
250 really good main battle tanks
leopard ones leopard twos Challenger
tanks American Abrams tanks are on their
way the French the AMX 10 that's another
tank busting system and if you look at
what the West has given Ukraine it isn't
just tanks and armored vehicles it's
aircraft it's helicopters it's it's
recovery Vehicles maintenance stuff
pontoon bridges lots and lots of
material anti-aircraft defenses missiles
they've given them something of the
whole range of Modern Warfare
if the ukrainians are able to use it
properly in an integrated way it's known
as combined arms operations if they're
able to conduct combined arms operations
at a very big level which is what
they'll have to do then that equipment
will really make a potential difference
because their equipment now is there in
numbers and it is a great deal better
than the Russian equipment that they're
up against